ukrainians are going to keep on fighting
there's no way that russia can hold
and occupy the territory that it's
capturing there's absolutely no way that
putin
wins this in the sense of controlling
and occupying and governing a a ukraine
in which every single man woman and
child uh is uh is against him in russian
history
uh and when you lose a war that's that's
often
when uh you're expected to bow out and
the russian people are under tremendous
pressure right now the oligarchs and
power brokers around putin are under
tremendous pressure right now they are
all losing
from this
self-inflicted uh crisis
and
[Music]
i i think
the the uncertainty that we have right
now about russia's political future is
better
than the certainty of a couple of months
ago when no one would have imagined any
political threat russia's vladimir putin
sought to shake the very foundations of
the freeway i had a long list for
president biden 10 days ago he's done
everything on my list for now
the sanctions are incredibly powerful
the russian economy is tanking
major russian companies like gasprom
have lost practically all of their value
gasprom is the number one energy company
in russia it was worth
over 65 billion dollars a few days ago
it is worth only 250 million dollars
today
the russian people are victims of putin
as well
um
most russians have absolutely no
interest in going to war with ukraine
killing ukrainians or putin's fantasies
of expanding
uh the russian
empire they're going to suffer
economically because of these sanctions
thousands of russians have been
incredibly brave and going out to the
streets to demonstrate and many of them
have been
arrested so this is a tragedy for the
russian people
almost as much as it's a tragedy for the
ukrainian people my my family survived
world war ii in poland they
they had to flee fighting they they had
to endure occupation
by
an enemy and so i feel
yeah a lot of personal kinship with the
people who are suffering and with the
people who are saying you know what
we're just going to fight for our
country
no matter what that's those are the
values that i was raised on we're likely
to have
several million ukrainians leave their
country i think the numbers are up to a
million already the europeans are being
extremely generous in taking people in
uh saying that they can stay for several
years and work and receive benefits we
should absolutely
be willing to take at least some small
share of people who were leaving ukraine
i think we would very much benefit from
any contributions they would make to
america